this is the classic first fight scene in
Kill Bill Vol 1 now look at the scene
again but without sound
Foley sounds tend to go unnoticed but
you realize just how important they are
when they're gone
Sean Brennan a Foley artist for movies
TV and video games showed us what kinds
of sounds can really make a fight scene
pop Foley sounds are created practically
and based on a character's movements and
interactions with the world naturally
they're a big part of fight scenes
Brennan has done Foley sounds for a
variety of fight scenes we met with him
at parabolic in New York it depends on
what's going on in the scene if it's a
real quiet moment I try to make it sound
as natural as possible but if you're in
a fight and there's a lot of noise going
on I will go over the top Foley is it
used for every single sound in a fight
scene certain sounds need to be created
digitally but there are a few crucial
elements to every fight scene where the
Foley artists work is necessary with the
hand-to-hand stuff sometimes I'll go
home covered in bruises for the most
part the sounds of hand-to-hand combat
are made exactly as you'd expect so when
doing punch sounds I'll always do like a
real natural sounding punch got that or
punch in the yarn sometimes then after
that I'll be fit up a pair of gloves can
add some extra thud to a punch these
sounds can work on their own or be
layered together meaning just one single
punch can contain three separate sounds
and in some cases even more than that
we'll get to layering a bit later even a
sound as simple as a punch can involve
some thinking outside the box in this
case we have a flank steak a piece of
steak like this is just it's very
similar to a human cheek yeah this helps
create a fleshy ER punch effect perfect
for a face punch plus it doesn't just
sound like a character simply punching
their own hand and of course you can't
have a fight without a few solid kicks
and who knows maybe you'll even have to
kick a door down just don't go into a
fight empty-handed some of these sounds
like bullets flying through the air
which involve no human interaction will
be created separately by sound editor
but somebody still has to handle a gun
Brennan often uses a door lock and puts
it against a rifle when it comes to
weapons using the real thing is
typically the best option well I have
some good looking swords but the problem
is they're decorative so there's a lot
of plastic on here they don't sound
great but any hits sounds cheap so
having something heavier some metal
stuff sounds much better
I get these kind of sounds
[Music]
[Music]
usually one Foley artist will make sound
for both sides of a given fight using
the real weapons creates the most
realistic sounds to get that iconic
sound of swords whooshing in the air
Foley artists will typically use wooden
dowels not very realistic at all but it
sounds great in the film it's still a
human element just you've heard that
before
say if a baseball flies about here or
something the dowels also work well for
kicking and flying through the air but
some of the most complex eye popping
sounds don't have anything to do with
weapons but rather the injuries when
creating the Foley sounds for injuries
things can get a little messy food
especially comes in handy here the
cellar is good really good for bone
cracks so you break it on give it a nice
give some more impact
and if you want to get a good stomp in
there then you'll have to step on a few
apples meanwhile other foods like raw
chicken and melon can also give you good
fleshy sounds smashing a watermelon can
give you an exploding head and while not
edible a wet leather towel sounds just
as gruesome a lot of these sounds could
end up being drowned out in the final
cut yet some of the most important
sounds Brennan must capture for a fight
are the ones you at least expect like
the rustling of clothes and so when the
actor goes to punch I just follow the
arm this is yet another sound the
audience is familiar with and therefore
one that can help bring them into the
scene these raw sounds are likely not
the only thing you'll hear in the final
product there's an extensive process
that follows and which sounds are edited
and layered together combining all the
different layers of the punch sound we
heard earlier really brings it to life
so here is just a regular punch and then
here's what the glove you know right now
they're not really mixed together but
already you can start to feel it being
heavier as far as the impact can get
pretty gross so sure your fight scene
can have the coolest moves and feature
the fiercest warriors but it will be
nothing without the right sound
see you sucker
[Music]
[Laughter]